Do you think you’ve lost by
being born black in a white country?
No.
I don’t look at it that way.
The greatest influence
in jazz of all time,
Louis Armstrong.
♫ Cold empty bed. ♫
Jazz almost stems
from Louis Armstrong.
♫ Wished I was dead. ♫
♫ What did I do ♫
Anybody who has uttered
a sound on American radio.
♫ To be so black and blue?♫
It’s because of
Louis Armstrong’s innovations.
♫ scatting ♫
He never would come out publicly,
but at home he had his opinions.
I’ve heard recordings
of Pops just talking.
He understood there
was a battle in this country.
There’s a rumor that
you invented scat sing.
It came to me just like that.
♫ scatting ♫
To be black in those days,
the discrimination
was unbelievable.
♫ Be so ♫
His own inner dignity
was able to make him prevail
over all these awful
conditions he worked with.
♫ What did I do ♫
He was the first
black movie
performer to have his
name above the title.
♫ I do ♫
He was trying to use
his music to reform
and lead the country closer
to his higher ideals.
Arkansas has decided to make
its own laws on the
subject of integration.
Louis said Ike and the
government could go to hell.
Everybody was astonished,
but privately he expressed
stuff like that all his life.
♫ My only sin ♫
All over the world.
♫ is in my skin ♫
He had the respect.
♫ They laugh at you ♫
And the love of millions.
♫ and scorn you too. ♫
♫ What did I do ♫
What more can any
man ask for?
♫ to be so black and blue?♫
Yeahhhhh.